this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisements and minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalist
we have a repeat guest in the building
or VP house
unfortunate circumstances I was hoping
we could talk about like I don't know
Stockton versus Jordan today I guess
that would make Ryan Jeff hornacek I
like basketball and I will try to keep
the mood relatively light but we have a
lot to talk about today we just recorded
an episode with Dave Rubin I think this
episode my actually come out a week
before that and there's a reason why I
want to get into it but we actually
recorded the episode with with Dave
Rubin right before all of these riots
started in Minneapolis yeah and he said
something on the podcast and I
challenged him on it although I do
regret not challenge him even farther
than what I did I mean basically we I
think what Ryan just said is we have to
agree to disagree on this one yeah I
really like Dave Rubin and while I don't
agree with everything he says I'm I
appreciate that he's open to a new line
of thinking and he's also very open to
changing his mind but one thing he said
TK is that America is the least racist
country in the world yeah and I mean
what I should have said is well what
about Mexico and Canada and and I should
have like listed I know a dozen other
countries that and and I think what's
going on right now with George Floyd is
his death his his murder I think you
could say by a police officer in
Minneapolis I guess the question is
isn't that part of something that is is
more systemic and it seems to me that
the Dave Rubin didn't I didn't believe
in sort of systemic oppression or racism
and and so today I just kind of want to
talk about race relations
it's a topic that I think it's
unfortunate we even have to talk about
because I believe yeah I believe in
colorblind it's not in the sense that
like I can't tell what color your skin
is but it should be as relevant as your
hair color like I will I should be able
to like tease my redhead friends that
they have red hair but like it shouldn't
it shouldn't it shouldn't be more than
that but unfortunately we have a long
history especially in this country of
oppression and racism and I'd like to
think we're out of that and many of us
are of a mindset where we are out of
that or at least we think we are but
today your good friend of ours I'm
you've been on the podcast I think more
than anyone else and this isn't
something we typically talk about on the
podcast and as opposed to me and Ryan
just get on here and talking about race
relations in this country I thought
maybe we since you're already in town
we're working on something else that I
can't tell people about yet it's a
top-secret project that will be out in
less than a year but pop Christmas album
I thought we would talk about this today
so maybe we start with with what's going
on in Minneapolis what happened to to
George Floyd from folks who who need to
be caught up on this and and what are
your initial thoughts on it maybe we
have a discussion maybe there's even
some things we disagree about and we can
go from there yeah I imagine most people
have seen the video or heard it but
maybe we should do a recap just so
people haven't seen it honestly yeah dug
into it's really disturbing yeah it's
very disturbing well it's harder to
actually find the original footage now
because everybody's so quick to put
their stamp on it you know the first 100
search results are gonna be videos of
someone providing commentary and then
they'll show you like ten seconds but
it's an eight-minute video and
essentially what you what you have is
basically from the perspective of what
you see you see police officers approach
a car and they they get a man out and
and from the angle you can't really tell
if there's resistance going on there but
but they pretty quickly cuff him and
they walk him you know on the sidewalk
and they give him instructions to sit
down and he sits now and him in an
officer are talking for a while as he's
cuffed and
for it and he does appear to me to be
like maybe he's drunk maybe he's hi
maybe he's like you know a little
loosey-goosey and as he cuz as he's
walking to the wall in handcuffs he's
not like walking you know the most but
it's one officer
there's more than one officer on the
scene but one officer clearly has the
situation under control and it doesn't
look like anybody is afraid it doesn't
look like anything abnormal is happening
in terms of you know violence and things
along those lines and then and some and
and so that's the footage that we see
from the security camera and then the
other footage the part that was released
first is what we see through the cell
phone camera where we see George Floyd
on the ground right outside the police
car and there's an officer that has his
knee on his neck and there and there's
another officer that's standing next to
him kind of keeping the people with the
cell phone camera at bay and the people
who are recording it and watching it
they're they're yelling at them like hey
like you don't have to keep your knee on
them like that you don't have to do it
that long like you guys have him
restrained right um
the officer didn't have his gun drawn or
anything like that it looks like you
know there's probably a few options for
how you can keep the guy restrained he's
handcuffed he's faced to the ground and
he's got his knee on his neck and I
believe it was about eight minutes mmm
but he kept his knee on his neck and and
after a while you can see the guy the
guy is saying multiple times I can't
breathe I can't breathe I need water I
can't breathe and the way this isn't the
first time we've heard I can't breathe
no no we haven't heard that the first
time and so he says it multiple times
and eventually you see the guy looks he
appears to be lifeless mm-hmm can't say
if he's lifeless or not but he appears
to be lifeless and and the whole time
and the people that are watching they
they are yelling at them saying you know
hey get off him or at least check his
pulse or whatever it may be and it just
kind of looks like the this is a bit of
interpretation but kind of looks like
the cops are double down a little bit
you know like you guys are yelling on us
we're gonna do this the way that we do
it we're we're the cops we're the
experts we know what we're doing and and
and and then so they called medical and
and you see like an ambulance pull up
and you see a couple of guys in police
uniforms get out I actually don't in the
video I actually don't you take a look
and tell me if you see something
different I actually don't see any any
people in any kind of gear that we
associate with medics when see yeah you
don't see anything like that you see if
you see a couple of cops you know get
out and and and and they're there
they're in their uniforms and they they
put him on the stretcher or whatever and
they put him in the truck and and
they're out of there and that's all we
see and and and of course there is a
context you know a lot of people feel a
lot of different ways about this and we
can dive into it not I love to
philosophize about it but it was a black
man and the officer who killed him was
white and there are some people in this
country who when they look at something
like that they say let's make race the
last thing that we bring up let's only
bring race into this if we've exhausted
all of the other explanations and then
there are other people in this country
who say no no no we can't treat race as
it's the last thing that we're going to
bring up we have to consider that as a
factor given the history of tension in
this country given the unique origin
story of this country as it pertains to
black people and white people given the
history of tension between police
officers and black folks this is a
problem this is reflective of something
systemic and so that's the debate and
it's not just the debate this comes on
the heels of of a few different
incidents that have occurred that that
appear to be racialized you know I
believe the woman is Amy Cooper there
was another incident where there was a
black man who from his side of the story
he was out bird-watching and from his
side of the story Amy Cooper was in
Central Park yeah that's right and Amy
Cooper had her dog off leash and they
got into an argument about that and you
know she wasn't agreeing with him about
leashing her dog and so according to him
he keeps treats on himself because this
is kind of a common problem and it's a
way that he forces people to leash their
dog because people generally don't like
other people giving their dogs treats so
he so he started to do that and then she
leashed her dog and then they began to
go back and forth 'no she's yelling at
him and you and he records that part the
where she's yelling at him her cell
phone and and she's threatening she says
I'm gonna call the police
and she specifically says I'm gonna call
the police and tell them that an
african-american man is threatening me
and and and so he says you can do
whatever you want right
and so she calls the cops and no
incident occurred you know with him but
she's pretty much been cancelled as a
result right like your job yeah she lost
her job and like man she's been taking
mad heat on on Twitter and again there's
a divide there are some people who are
saying hey what she did was bad what she
did was stupid but that guy isn't
perfect either and maybe we should treat
this like a normal human altercation
right how many times on a given week do
two people disagree about something act
and mature about it and just say things
they shouldn't say but everybody at
least leaves physically safe like why
make it about race and then there are
others who are saying hey look if for no
other reason than the fact that she
linguistically invoked the term
african-american we can't run away from
the possibility of race right because
she she knew that that would have power
when she said I'm she was implying like
yeah the cops if I tell them you're a
black guy the cops are gonna be out here
even faster yeah cuz yeah I'm gonna tell
him that you're in African American we
pause real quick on the two terms here
so so my brother who happens to be black
always has a problem with the term
african-american now he's always messed
with people we worked at the same
restaurant together in high school and
even someone called in African marries
he would always say like well I've never
been in Africa you know he would like to
just kind of mess with people too and
like like provoke them because they were
a little bit uncomfortable about it it
and it seems to me like words like that
are often euphemisms in a way and in
almost a sign later when we maybe even
on the maximum up so don't talk about
virtue signaling a little bit but we see
it being taken a bit too far when for
example there was a reporter who was
reporting on South Africa and instead of
saying the white South Africans in the
black South African she said because she
was very caught up in the political
correct speak politically correct speak
she said the
white South Africans and the
african-american South Africa wait a
minute and you start to realize that
some of these terms while well intended
they also that they don't always make
sense in different contexts yeah where
do you fall on on on euphemisms like
this yeah man you know I think the
purpose of language is to try to create
a bridge across which we can transfer
ideas and understand each other to
create an efficient way for us to
exchange thoughts and feelings I don't
think the purpose of language is to put
ourselves in a position where we have to
walk around on eggshells and we're
afraid to speak like oh do I got the
right name that I call you the right
name right um if there were not room for
us to get it wrong there would not be
room for us to learn for what does it
mean to learn other than to to make a
mistake or to commit an error and
receive feedback from reality that says
there's a better way to do that so we
have to allow room for people to give us
feedback about what manner of speaking
to them is most effective when it comes
to when it comes to talking with people
and I think there's an interesting
debate going on right now about being
offended and and you have some people
who kind of dismiss the value of that
they say well if you're offended you're
too sensitive you're a baby things along
those lines but the way I like to think
of it is this if you are the one who's
communicating the question you have to
ask yourself is is it important to you
that people receive your message if it's
not then you're communicating either to
hear yourself speak or for entertainment
or to appease the people that already
agree with you and I actually think
that's okay I like funny
I like provocative nough sand I like
entertainment too and let's be clear at
least half the people in politics and in
discussions on race they're not speaking
to convince people who think differently
than them they are speaking for no other
reason than they know there is a
guaranteed response from the audience
that's backing them right it's
entertainment or it's preaching to the
choir and if that's your goal then all
right like you're getting what you want
right on the other hand if your goal is
to get someone to listen to you then it
behooves you out of self-interest not
out of political correctness not out of
subservience it behooves you
to adopt a manner of speaking that will
allow you to get what you want out of
that communication so if I say Josh can
you hand me that pen and you break down
and start crying and you're like to get
admitted well you're always gonna talk
to me that way hmm
I'm so selfish I want the pen right and
if I see that my way of talking to you
is preventing me from it from getting
that pen I be who me to figure you out I
want to figure you out not because I
love you not because I think you're
crying for a legitimate reason up here
I'm thinking that's a really stupid
thing to cry about but I care about the
pencil and as long as you're sitting
here crying about it
it's delaying me from getting what I
want so I'm gonna try to learn from this
experience and ask myself what's a way
of asking people like Josh for the pen
for the pencil that allows me to
smoothly and efficiently get what I want
because that's a better experience for
me it's not about placating you let's so
let's map this on to what's going on
right now and I mean what you're saying
is a perfect analogy for social media as
well I mean it's the reason why I
wouldn't engage in any conversation like
this on social media
not because it lacks nuance I'm fine I'm
a good writer I can I can include nuance
and even even in a tweet but the problem
is is is there are people who are ready
for rage there it is a it is a place in
which the the inciting of of rage and
anger
and maybe even recreational outrage is
it it's completely different from this
where we can have our conversation and
it it almost seems like they set up
social media to be a place for
conversation but it is not really it is
not really that and Ryan you and I found
this early on we started doing remote
podcasting like it was fine for a little
while but it wasn't the same thing as
even getting in a room with someone
right being able to have this
conversation you miss something yeah
when with the digital screen the barrier
there when I think about social media I
one of the problems to a thing and maybe
this is what you're hinting towards is
that
you know if you were to make a statement
no matter what that statement is like
you could say it to not offend some
people but there's no way you would not
be able to not offend everyone like
there's somebody primed and ready to be
offended no matter how you put something
well having a personality is offensive
right inherently so if you genuinely
believe that you have a way of being or
a or a way of communicating that offends
no one I can assure you and and I say it
as nicely as I can I can assure you you
are naive and I can assure you that you
have not experienced the world broadly
enough to meet the kind of people who
could be ticked off by every aspect of
who you are and I can introduce them to
you if someone out there if you think
your non offensive and everybody loves
you I can introduce you to several
people who I hate you for that reason
you meet him he's at but yeah you know
having a personality is offensive and so
yeah you're never going to know ahead of
time you're not gonna have guarantees
ahead of time about what works but part
of relationship building is being open
to the feedback that we get now we all
have significant others so I'll use an
example there that I think anybody would
a significant other can understand how
many times have you used a word that has
worked for you all your life
mm-hmm and it's created no problems for
you but for whatever reason in a way
that you couldn't predict you might use
that innocent neutral sounding word with
your significant other and it rubs them
the wrong way right they don't like it
for me that word is sure and I
discovered that when my wife would say
sure to me right with if I say hey do
you want to do such-and-such and you say
sure I react as if you're kind of
blowing me off and like you big you're
doing me a favor sure what the heck is
that right and I had to discover that
about myself and and it's something that
she discovered about me and and look you
know I'm flexible enough to allow people
to say sure to me but there are moments
in life where you kind of discover all
right I don't think there's anything
wrong with the way that I said that but
it doesn't work it just doesn't work and
I can exercise my right to talk the way
that I want but I rather get what I want
then be right there's this awesome verse
in the Bible that says all things are
permissible but
things are not profitable and when
you're choosing your actions in life do
you just want to limit yourself to
what's permissible well I have the right
to do that legally I can do that you
can't lock me in jail for talk to you
however I want I proved my point but
yeah like I want something out of the
conversation so I'm gonna structure my
speech in a way that I believe will be
most profitable and I think that's
something that gets lost in these
discussions and I have a theory why but
I want to pause cuz I just feel like
I've been talking for long I have a
theory why what you just mentioned sort
of tangentially you you alluded to this
other conversation we were having with
Dave Rubin
and he said he didn't believe in in hate
speech which I thought was a strange way
to phrase it
because I believe that hate speech
exists i I don't know whether or not it
should ever be illegal I believe in
freedom of speech as well and so I
believe that you're allowed to use hate
speech yeah and this is another thing my
brother would often say is like I would
rather someone you know be racist to my
face then like behind my back sort of
thing and talk about that talk about
hate speech and and what are your
thoughts on I actually I think you
probably even have a different thought
about you you would rather someone well
you tell me would you rather someone be
openly here sort of overtly racist or
covertly racist overtly yeah yeah that's
what I prefer because I believe that
ideas have consequences and I love to
see alignment between people's ideas
actions and consequences the more you
are able to hide who you are in what you
think then the less you are facing
reality and I think that's worse for you
I think that's worse for everyone I
think it's good to get a dosage of
reality right so yeah I prefer it
overtly
and I I actually support policies and
practices that encourage people to come
forward and be real about what they
really think because you're not doing me
any favor by pretending to be something
other than what you are and I also we
don't have to get into this I think
there are a number of free market
dynamics that punish that kind of
behavior swiftly if we
don't protect people and make it so darn
easy for them to hide but um you know as
far as hate speech you know I haven't I
haven't heard Rubin talk about this so
I'm not sure what he means but I'm gonna
take a guest I'm gonna take a guess at
what he doesn't mean I don't think he
means it's impossible to use speech to
express hate because he gets that as
YouTube comments all the time right
people saying I hate you I think I think
what he's probably getting at is
something along the lines of we
shouldn't have this special category of
negative speech that's exclusively
reserved for for maybe bad things said
about minorities right like like we
already have hate speech in the form of
you're stupid you're an idiot you don't
know what you're talking about and
you're dumb you should shut up and in
your podcast right now because you're a
worthless piece of whatever whatever we
already have that and I think what he
would argue is hey whether someone hates
you for being black for being a woman
for wearing black for loving women
whatever it may be
it's just speech and some of that speech
is hateful
some of it is loving some of this
constructive summit is some of it is
deconstructive but if we can kind of
step back and maybe like neutralize all
of the connotations that come with hate
speech maybe we can think about it a
little bit more critically and clearly
I'm guessing that he's getting at
something like that now what he I think
what he was saying was how you can say
like I hate you and you'd be like oh I
hate you or you can look at someone but
like I hate you yeah and it's it's the
it's the yeah the the intent that's
where it comes from so I think what he
was trying to say is that yes you can be
a hateful person you could use words to
be hateful yeah but there's not there's
no words that you could just put a label
on and say well that's considered hate
speech am i right on yeah I think I
think so what do you think is America
the most that the least these races
country in the world first up I don't
even know what data you look at yeah to
make that judgment all I can tell is
like what you know what's in the media
what's you know what are the tensions
that are out there what are things that
you know consistently happen but it's
like I mean is there even data you can
look at to say the whole people what
country yeah yeah but it's but it would
be an opinionated poll do you feel yeah
how would you measure that because most
people who believe in racism and yes
there are people who don't believe in
racism in fact I think belief in racism
is more offensive now then then actual
racism but that's another topic what do
you mean by the belief in racism is more
offense more offensive than racism yes
that if we are not seeing it right now
mm-hmm and I can say this without
requiring you guys to take any
particular side on it but there are
people who if they observe something
that another group of people say that's
racist
they are not offended by what they
observe but they are deeply offended by
the claim that that's racist okay so so
what I'm saying is if you if you want to
make a whole lot of people mad I can
give you a really easily
easy predictable way mm-hmm just go say
something's racist yeah just go again
right and what I'm saying is like belief
that racism is a good explanation for
many things that happen in our world is
a very offensive belief to many people
I'm not saying this if this Jimmy so if
I said that blue shirts racist you're
saying that's more offensive than no no
what he's saying is that there are can
we use George Floyd just as an example
it's - it right um
the debate right now I'm not saying it's
the real debate I think there's a more
fundamental important debate we should
be having but the debate right now is
whether or not this is about race you
listen to the people that are mad at the
folks that like you have people that are
mad about George Floyd dying mm-hmm okay
right and then you have people that are
mad at those folks for making it about
race you see what I'm saying okay right
um so so on one hand you have a group of
people saying this was racist and that
offends me and then you have another
group saying you're making something
that really isn't about race about race
and that offends me I'm offended you're
offended yeah yeah well let me let me
just add this real quick there's also
this there's a great way to shut down
every conversation yeah also is to say
tell someone they're racist right and so
it wouldn't offend me if like someone on
Twitter was like hey you
racist I would just be like okay why
because to me like who I don't know that
person
we're frien were to say hey you're
racist I would just like well you're
wrong you explain why you I think
someone just tweeted human like it says
your murderer like me right yeah but
there are there there are people who
want to continue to engage in a
conversation with someone else and
that's a great conversation stopper
because yeah it's it responding to that
is like responding to you TK so explain
to me why you beat your wife and it's
like well I don't beat my butt and all
of a sudden it shuts the whole thing
down yeah yeah yeah I get what you're
saying um so let me address this
question is America the most racist so
first I agree with Ryan I don't even
know how we began measuring that and
quantified that no no no no so the
actual quote is America is the least
racist country on earth okay yeah so
agree or disagree
I would like to reject that statement as
so utterly irrelevant that I would never
waste effort forming an opinion or not
mmm why is is my marriage the least or
most happiest on the planet who cares
right like like know your wife cares I
know no no no she doesn't here's what
she cares about she cares about our
happiness based on our goals right so if
we're not achieving our goals it doesn't
matter if we're more happy than you and
X mm-hmm
right and and and if we are it doesn't
matter if you guys have more I mean
isn't that what this whole minimalism
message is about right like disparaging
your own level of happiness and success
which you otherwise would be content
with because you see somebody that has
more right or letting yourself off the
hook if you know you're not doing what
you're supposed to do you're gonna let
yourself off the hook with something
weak like oh but I'm the least you don't
like imagine if I'm a bigot right now
but I'm around a bunch of other guys
that are more bigger than me it's okay
for me to let myself off to look like
I'm the least bigoted guy in the room
yeah I'm the least bigoted guy in a room
it doesn't care man you're still a bigot
maybe we should spend more time working
on that then taking pride in the fact
that you're the least of the worst I'm a
bigot but I'm the least yeah actually
that's a great way to put it
it wasn't phrased as the most not racist
it was the least right like like when
you think about they say yes we're
racist but we're not as racist as what
Honduras I have no idea like what you're
even comparing it to say you're both of
your points yeah I don't know how you
would measure that so so TK I think
that's a phenomenal point in that
question or in that statement there is
there is an you're admitting in a way
that okay the we're still a racist
country then but by making that
statement in a way yeah I think it's
kind of a distraction that misses the
point for why you feel the need to say
that to people right yeah and here's why
so yes there is a celebratory aspect to
that if there if there is a certain vice
that we are not as terrible at
committing as other countries then then
maybe that's an indicator that we're
doing something right and we should take
pride in that however the people in this
country who complain about race complain
about it because they live in this
country right they're not they're not
invoking the issue in some abstract
philosophical sense that's detached from
human experience there's no one saying
you know America's well maybe there is
somebody say America's most races maybe
there are somebody saying but like
that's not why people care right it's
not like if you whip out a stat that
says actually they're more racist in
Sweden and I can prove it with this
empirical data here that that was I feel
safer right like oh man my bad bro like
I made that mistake you know the the
people who complain about it complain
because they're trying to say something
about their lived experience right in
this country I don't know what's going
on in Russia I don't live there and even
if we are less racist than them can we
talk about my life can we talk about our
life can we talk about what's happening
here so I would love to talk with him
about that I would love to go back and
forth on that and I listen charitably
and so forth but yeah for me I don't
care to form an opinion about how less
terrible we are than other countries in
that respect what I care about is saying
hey as a country let's play our own game
let's set standards for success just
like the best
athletes just like the best
entrepreneurs just like the best
achievers what do they say we're not
going to measure success by
outperforming our opponents we're gonna
decide what our goals are what our
vision is and we're gonna play our own
game we're gonna compete with ourselves
so that even if we win 60 games we're
gonna say all right we got the best
record in the league but less ways 65
like where does that come from it
doesn't come from saying oh yeah we're
better than everybody else
it comes from always striving for more
and more greatness you know yeah how
about we talk about the protests and
eventually the riots another euphemism
here is I have seen several news
networks again I think maybe being
afraid like there I've seen my anchors
or your reporters whatever in front of
like burning buildings and calling it a
protest yeah yeah what blows my mind is
cuz you just had those Michigan protests
and everyone shows up with guns but the
people who show up with no guns it
actually turns more violent and damages
more property yeah I mean it's yeah yeah
I don't I don't know what that says but
that's conflating a few things here that
there's I mean yes the the people show
up with guns are protesting and what I
would say is an absurd way totally agree
right I believe in the right to protest
and I think it makes a lot of sense to
be able to protest however and this
might be a controversial statement I
don't think in our lifetime so let's say
in the last 40 years I don't know how
effective protesting has ever been this
is John Mayer line about who's ever
changed their mind by what was written
on a sign but you know it's messed up
though is because of these riots like
the cop got arrested well that's my
point is there are times where yeah do
you think it's because of the because of
the riots though yes and let me let me
just say this and then TK I want to get
your opinion so we can talk about MLK
versus like Malcolm X but Martin Luther
King
he totally condemned rioting but he also
simultaneously condemned the conditions
that led to rioting and so if we were to
move remove it from this context all
together you go back to the the Boston
Tea Party what was that that was a riot
mm-hmm and and we might have caught we
might call it euphemistically a protest
now
but that was a riot and and what's
happening now well why did why did the
Boston Tea Party happened because they
felt like they had exhausted all of
their means with the government right
they had taken it to the extreme and
they didn't felt like there was nothing
else they could do and now you have
people in Minneapolis who many of them
well let's say some of them are
certainly opportunists who don't care
about justice or anything like that yeah
if you're taking a hammer to a ATM and
the target parking lot you probably
don't care that much about justice but
there are many people who are beginning
to riot right now and some of it is is
violent some of it is not is just
destructive but not your violent I don't
know we can talk about the definition of
violence here too but there are there
are some people now who have felt like
we've exhausted every avenue we've tried
to protest we've already said I can't
breathe
we've had t-shirts and bandanas we've
talked about it we've created hashtags
we've we've done everything we can do
and we are still not being heard well
how do we how do we solve that now well
the the next level is let's do a Boston
Tea Party right now it's gonna be
different from that because there are
different circumstances whatever we're
also in the middle of a pandemic which
makes things very strange right there's
already boarded up retail shops around
all over the place and so you you're in
a weird place it seems to me that you
could and this is no pun intended you
could have more targeted riots that
wouldn't happen at Target you would you
know like what they did in Columbus
yesterday apparently whether we're
recording this on on Friday what is the
date today the 29th yeah Friday May 29th
in Columbus they like raided the the
state the State House the in the Capitol
building and in in Minneapolis they're
raiding police stations a government
buildings that that to me makes more
sense I'm not again III would still
condemn it the same way Martin Luther
King would condemn it yeah but I also
condemn the circumstances that led to it
mm-hmm
yeah you know if I were interested in
co-opting a legitimate
movement right let's just say I were an
evil villain of the interval villain I
had a lot of connections a lot of
resources and I saw something like the
George Floyd thing happen and I see
people calling for these officers jobs
and then I see people saying that's not
enough and I hear people saying we need
to make changes to how we do policing
we're tired of this I see people
starting to protest I see everybody
writing social media post about it and I
wanted to co-op that I would try to
create a distraction
I think I would be quite pleased with
something like what we're seeing with
the riots because it would then allow me
to shift the discussion from this
uncomfortable topic that has been a
problem for a long time that we have
still haven't figured out how to solve
and work together on to something more
like hey y'all we all agree that as a
tragedy that's pretty obvious but you
know you shouldn't be breaking into
buildings now but but I'm not saying
that and I want to be clear in fact the
reason the riots are actually stemming
this conversation right now how many
other black people have died in the last
several years when we haven't had we
haven't sat down had this conversation
right I mean I got you on that and by
the way I'm not I'm not even saying this
as a way to justify riots but there's a
specific reason why I said if I were a
villain who wanted to co-opt the
movement because I believe that is a
real possibility that we cannot dismiss
so for instance there was one video of a
guy in a neighborhood who you know who
was going around like break-in windows
right and you could see the black folks
trying to stop him you can see the
windows at an Auto Zone yeah yeah and
then when they could they confronted the
guy you know he threatened one of the
guys that was following him around and
then he eventually got out of there and
apparently the guy's ex-wife or
something like that identified him as a
cop Yeah right
yeah undercover cop ya know what's up
with that what's up with that by the way
oh it's just that one time it's just
that one time right like that only
happened one time but there are a number
of videos like that that will force you
to ask some important questions about
what's really going on because if you go
into these neighbor
a lot of people who live in these
neighborhoods that care about their
neighborhoods and yeah let's be real
there are people that have no business
using this as an excuse to destroy their
own communities I do believe that's
terrible
but at the same time this is not a
monolithic group it's not like it's just
black people out there doing it it's
people of all colors and it's not merely
the case that there are just people from
one political party right or that it's
only civilians and there are no cops
being involved in this can I can I
answer that I felt a weird sense of
pride like a collectivism almost but I
saw the videos of their multiracial
riots because I lived in Cincinnati
during the 2001 riot yeah yeah and I was
I was in a car with four other black
people and they still threw a trash can
at my car because I was like there was a
there's one white guy driving through
here and so like I don't like oh well
like I could be a part of this group of
rioting if I really wanted to it was
felt like a strange kind of like
regressing but progress at the same rate
progressive regression so let's let's
talk TK about these about these riots
about these protests as well because
there are also protests that are going
on all over the country and Memphis and
Louisville and Columbus and Los Angeles
and and in other cities as well and and
so most of it is actually protesting we
don't hear that as loud as we hear the
the riots though and again well I don't
I don't condone it I I start to
understand it to a great extent I
understand it on two levels one is the
opportunistic level but the looting the
self-serving the pallets of flat-screen
TVs
that's not justice but there's something
else going on here that is a cry for
justice maybe yeah absolutely
what will an understandable expression
of anger and rage right um for the most
part rage is is a way of saying I'm so
hurt by what I'm experiencing but I also
feel so powerless and I don't know what
to do think about it
violent scale where you're so mad at
somebody and they say hey is everything
okay what's wrong and you pout and you
mopey like I'm fine now it now the truth
is you're lying you're not fine right
there's a problem the problem is you're
hurt right you're deeply hurt you've
been wounded and you don't know what to
do about it
you're you're so deeply wounded that
you're afraid that if I give you my
vulnerability given the trust that you
just broke you might you might wound me
even more deeply yeah right and I don't
know how to express my hurt to you in a
way that's gonna give me what it is I
need I don't even know how to do that
right so so I expressed that as I'm fine
that's not an expression of power
although it does cause the other person
to squirm and beg and be like well what
can I do to make it right it feels
powerful but it feels powerful because
it's it's the kind of power you it's
it's the best kind of power you have
access to when you don't know what to do
with your feelings and and and we as
human beings we respond to extremes you
know we can take it outside of race
outside of riots we respond to extremes
how do we know someone has a gambling
problem is it because they stopped
showing up for work and they're always
short on cash no we usually see the
problem before then but those are the
extremes that make us pay attention and
decide all right we better do something
about it how do we know somebody how do
we know somebody has an alcohol problem
you know I you know I talked to someone
once who told me that they kind of
suspected that their husband had an
alcohol problem when every morning
before going to work he would make a
Long Island iced tea and drinking on his
drive to work hmm you know but but it
wasn't until two years of doing that
every day that it began to become
something more like domestic violence
that you know action you know it was
taken on it and so sometimes you know
not just sometimes we tend to be
responsive to extremes that doesn't mean
the extremes are good that means that
our ability to figure out what to do
about problems before they come become
extremes is really really bad and so
whether it's the people that are doing
the rioting or the people that are
freaking out saying how do we stop the
rioting this is all a symptom of a more
fundamental problem which is we've got
some fears some vulnerabilities some
hurt some wounds and we don't know how
to come together and talk and create it
in a way that's going to make the world
better
so we suppress them we bottle them up
and then they come out in the worst kind
of ways which is what we're saying right
now I want to talk to you about I want
to talk to you about that specifically I
want to talk about systemic oppression
and in the circumstances that lead to
something like this I need to take a
quick break Sean maybe we've got some
voicemails some-some listener tips and
tricks we could insert right here and
then we'll be right back with more with
TK Coleman I want to talk to you about
is indifference the enemy I want to talk
about what can we do and also there's a
bunch more things I want to talk to you
about let's listen to some listener tips
and comments at this point and then
we'll be right back with TK Coleman hi
my name is Jamie I'm calling from Los
Angeles California and then so leave
this a long time ago I feel like it was
on one of the debt episodes but it
actually pertains also to the budget a
friend of mine I can't take total credit
for this but recommended that I check in
with my cell phone bill I had noticed it
was really high for two cell phones and
I admit even though I'm very organized
when the bill comes electronically
I don't always look at it so I won't
give the provider her name per se but I
did call I asked to make my bill lower
which they did have something to offer
but then we combed through the bill on
the phone and I had apparently some kind
of featured at 399 a month for
international calling I never call
international calling so that came off I
had some kind of ringtone charge that
was happening I didn't know about anyway
long story short I found all kinds of
hidden charges that I did not know that
were happening for years I lowered my
bill right then and there by $60 I
wanted to wait a few months to see if it
actually stayed that way and it has so
it's been about six months so
when we get bills electronically we
don't always look at them so I just urge
people to check in to especially a cell
phone bill that has some of these
charges we might not even know cuz $60
times 12 months of a year has been a
huge savings for me as I try to get out
of debt hi this is Joe in Dallas and I
was burning through some old minimalist
podcasts and I heard you talking about
the ketogenic diet and cure bacon and I
just wanted to throw out there that they
do so Unser's bacon at a lot of places
now including Walmart that have less
than one gram of carbs I want to talk to
you about indifference and it seems to
me that maybe indifference is the enemy
here and I don't just mean with the
white people or what any I even I hate
talking these terms because you just
said the you obviously black people
aren't a monolith white people certainly
aren't a monolith in this country and oh
you guys get this certainly a monolith
[Laughter]
like I think it of like there's there's
Richard Spencer and there's Eminem and
then there's like this weird spectrum in
between right hey there's Larry elder
and dr. Dre oh that's so true yeah yeah
Larry elder I think they both from South
Central oh man yeah well we won't talk
about larry elder right now but or dr.
dre but we will talk about indifference
and here's what I mean by this like I
think most of us are indifferent most of
the time yeah yeah regardless of what
gender we happen to be a part of and I
don't mean indifferent to everything
I mean indifferent to most things that
don't apply to us or like we feel like
don't apply to us and I think that's out
of necessity we can't be passionate
about everything because if you're
passionate about everything you're
passionate about nothing you could tweet
that John all right so so let's let's
talk about in
especially when in cases like this and
maybe as much as I hate to say it maybe
it takes riots that I condemn to to stop
some of that indifference
hmm I don't I don't think it takes riots
to stop indifference any more than it
takes extreme behavior in other areas of
life to stop addiction or abuse we can
always see the red flags we can always
see the symptoms right you might see
them but we don't act on it yeah yeah
but you know if we have a pattern of not
responding to symptoms do we want to
corner ourselves into a position that
says all right the solution then is to
make sure that we really give somebody
something to be afraid about or do we
say maybe this is an indicator that
something needs to change and how we
educate one another that there's
something we're not being conditioned to
respect as being in conflict with our
well being with our self-interests
because because the whole premise of
saying people ought to be concerned
about things that they don't care about
is that this really does have something
to do with their health with their
well-being but they're not feeling the
urgency and so perhaps a better job
needs to be done and having
conversations about what does and does
not affect your health and well-being in
fact in my coaching experience whenever
I'm in a situation where I've got to get
someone to care about something that
they don't care about I'm never
successful at the level of saying well
let me escalate the consequences so that
you can you know it can really cost you
something
I only succeed when I listen to that
person talk about what they already care
about and if I create a bridge between
their existing goals their existing
priorities and how something like this
might affect it so if I'm talking to a
child who just can't understand well why
should I care about shaking people's
hands after a sport game why should I
care about sharing some of my candy with
that kid who you know wants a piece you
know that conversation goes in the
direction of hey look you have the right
to not shake anyone's hands you're not
gonna go to jail for that you have the
right to say no
but here's what's gonna happen when you
treat people that way that's gonna be
reflected back to you in the way they
treat you and so when you come back to
me crying saying uh they don't give me
any candy they don't invite me out when
they play they never let me play
football with them I'm gonna establish a
causal connection between your behavior
and your results right that that you
can't just be careless about other
people's challenges without that somehow
compromising your own ability to create
the results that matter most to you can
we say that about police we could say
that about the police in LA hey hey I
know most police don't it's weird
because of how I grew up around a large
portion of black people I I developed an
unhealthy distrust for the police where
I lived and I in a weird way I think
it's still sort of embedded in me and
and because I know that like when I was
with friends who were black we got
pulled over far more frequently then
when I was with by myself it was just me
and Ryan driving down the street and
that's a real thing that happened to me
in my life you're growing up my brother
was tased twice not it's nothing he was
doing nothing wrong but he was doing
nothing different from what I have done
really quickly I have offended many
people just by telling the truth about
experiences like that and I have never
once in my life coupled one of those
stories with and you ought to vote for
this person so you can dismiss me in the
stereotypical way that everybody does by
saying oh you're a liberal
oh you're just you just hate Trump all
you're just trying to get by in an
office whatever you will never find well
I know you and none of those you know I
am taking this one to my grade man you
will never find TK Coleman using
whatever influence God gives him to put
the attention on a politician that
that's one that I'm taking to the grave
that is a life goal you know but I have
a finless Ryan runs
[Laughter]
but you know like I've offended people
by sharing those stories but like we can
separate it from politics for a second
we can separate it from like but is that
the conservative position or the liberal
position like if I accept that story is
true does that concede this you know no
no just like your the story I mean we
grew up in when I was in the fifth grade
my brothers are older than me we grew up
in the inner city West Side of Chicago
but in fifth grade we moved to a suburb
in Illinois a Westchester all-white
suburb I went from the only white people
I saw as being on TV to to you know
white people be in all around me right
yeah and I remember things like my
father had a nice Lincoln Towncar and my
brother he would drive us to the park to
play basketball or he'd drive us to
school and it was just common young
black do in that town car you better
pull him over and just make sure
everything's okay just give that some
extra attention because what in the
world is an 18 19 year old black guy
doing in that car now you may say oh but
maybe it's not about race maybe it's the
fact that he was just young right
because that is sort of odd for a young
guy but the fact was we lived in a
pretty wealthy neighborhood all the kids
I went to school with they came from
wealthier families a lot of those kids
drove nice cars like that and couldn't
identify with that experience of being
pulled over right and fortunately the
overwhelming majority of those
experiences were not dangerous they
didn't involve anything that went on too
long but you just sort of accept it that
getting your trunk popped and getting
your car searched being asked to step
out you know answering a bunch of
questions you don't exam - that was the
thing that happens on more than one
occasion
not when I'm by myself ever but yeah
yeah guns drawn up and going up to the
window nothing and now if I get pulled
over I still have that weird thing in
the back of my mind where it's like yeah
I feel nervous even though I remind
myself ah I'm white it's okay which is a
weird thing to have to like remind
myself but it's that's the truth yeah
and that right there shows you the
disparity so I don't know do we call
this systemic oppression do we call it
systemic racism and do you believe in
those things
see I do but here's where we have to
carefully define our terms and make some
important distinctions I think one of
the things that makes philosophical
discussions on race so difficult is that
we spend most of our time debating the
implication rather than debating the
idea an implication is what you think it
would mean if you were to acknowledge
someone's point as true an idea is
simply the content that's being proposed
I'm not asking that I'm not asking about
the implications I'm simply asking you
we mentioned Larry elder so I'll bring
him back up yeah well he would say
there's no such thing as systemic races
but I'm gonna tell you why I think so
many people say that in spite of
evidence to the contrary so this whole
distinction between debating implication
and debating ideas is in the political
world that distinction doesn't exist if
you believe in something like systemic
racism that pretty much commits you to
the liberal position on what government
ought to do about it
and so I would contend that most
conservatives simply cannot afford to
acknowledge points that liberals make
about race because that would feel like
they are conceding liberals points about
the role that government should play in
doing something about that problem which
is why one of the number one response is
you hear being made to people who
believe in things like systemic racism
is stuff like all you stupid liberal oh
you're just a commie right because it's
equated with being political and and for
me I like to make that distinction
because I like to say hey look how about
we just discuss the ideas how about how
about we look at you know black fear of
police officers not as something that
supports or refutes any particular
political position because there are a
wide variety of ideas that we can have
about the role that government should
and should not play in solving that
let's just look at experience and
philosophize about it um and so I think
part of the problem here is people put a
race on a pedestal and there are two
ways you can do that one way as you can
say everything is about race
another ways you can say Oh race is so
evil it's so bad that we can't let
anything be about race unless that's the
last possible explanation oh yeah that
guy he's a pedophile but he's not a
racist oh that guy's a murderer but he's
not a racist oh that guy's the most evil
man I've ever met but he's not a racist
right I mean it's like we look at
racists as being so evil so unforgivable
so devilish that we can't ever invoke
that as an explanation on us we've got
all the evidence in the world but I
think we put it on a pedestal because am
I to really be so naive that I think the
human race which has a demonstrated
ability to be tremendously superficial
in its capacity to judge other people
like people judge each other and look
down on each other because of their
economic status because of the clothes
because of their hairstyle because of
their accent and the way they talk and
we can just limit ourselves to examples
of people within the same race we as
human beings man we judge each other for
some petty stuff am i right to be so
naive that I but that I believe that for
some reason we magically lose that
ability when it comes to race that race
is somehow the one superficial area of
judgment that we never negatively invoke
no I wasn't born yesterday if we can
hate each other for our weight if we can
hate each other for our money and for
our outfits and our accents and what
school we went to and who we date and
who were friends with surely we can hate
each other for race so why should I
believe that's an exception I definitely
believe that there are all sorts of
stupid silly things in this world that
happened because we judge each other on
superficial things and race is just one
of many things so because I don't put
race on a pedestal I don't feel the need
to make something about race but I also
don't feel the need to make sure
something is not about race yeah
like there's nothing about my political
philosophy that's going to be affected
by accepting or denying the existence of
systemic racism right and I don't think
that's true for most people in fact I
believe that if you are in certain
political groups for you to agree with
one position position would cause you to
have problems with your people right so
in terms of what what I what I think
exists I do believe it exists and here's
what I mean by
that I believe that systems exists and I
believe that whether intentionally or
unintentionally systems
disproportionately affect different
groups of people okay there are actually
some systems that disproportionately
affect groups of white people there are
some systems that disproportionately
affect groups of black people whether
there's anybody behind the scenes
pulling the lever like hahahaha today
I'm gonna bring down all the people of
this group that's irrelevant you judge
it by its actual effects not by the
intentions that drive it right so if you
take something for instance like drug
policies mm-hmm you know hey if you're a
champion of Liberty like I am you know
you've got to believe that it's all wack
you know the war on drugs what a facade
what a facade at least if you want to be
logically consistent and champion
yourself as someone who is a voice for
the philosophy of freedom if you want to
play that small government car if you
want to play that free market card you
want to play that pro Liberty card I
want to hear what is your defense for
this ridiculous war on drugs what is
your defense of that and that is
something that disproportionately
affects poorer people and black people
does that mean that someone is trying to
be racist no not necessarily
maybe maybe so but but what what I want
to do is set this up in a way that I
don't require you to believe a certain
theory about someone's intentions in
order to acknowledge someone's negative
results right because you know if you
take my wallet and I say what the heck
man you stole my wallet and you're like
well you think I'm a bad person what do
you think I don't have any money I don't
even have that debate I had good
intentions and taking your wallet yeah
right you know I don't want to have that
debate I just want to point to the
result like but you stole my wallet
can you give that back and never do that
again and I Knight and I don't want to
have to commit to a theory on if you're
a good guy if you need it the money bah
blah blah blah and I feel the same thing
about race like or anything in life
let's just analyze the results and if
we're not getting results that work
let's figure out something that does so
that is what I mean when I say systemic
injustice yes I believe in the
existence of systems and I believe that
systems have disproportionate
consequences and since I believe that
some systems are inherently oppressive
because they are propped up by a
monopoly on violence yeah I believe
that's a system of oppression for sure
there's so many more things I want to
talk to you about on the maximal episode
we're gonna talk about virtue signaling
maybe we're gonna talk about how maybe
this is a good thing especially during
the pandemic and maybe we can debate on
that a little bit I want to talk about
this onion headline protesters
criticized for looting businesses
without forming private equity firm
first shot at Bain Capital I think but
we'll talk about that I want to talk
about Joe Biden's comment about you
ain't black if you if you vote for
Donald Trump which I found to be
interesting I won't talk about white
supremacy and misogyny and chauvinism I
want to talk about privilege white
privilege male privilege black privilege
I wanna talk about black lives matter
and antifa I want to talk about anti
racism and so-called anti racism which
is a really fascinating and other
euphemism perhaps by the way my wife was
like what do y'all want to talk about I
was like hopefully anything but politics
I love this is I has become a it's sad
like you said it's sad this is become a
political issue yeah we're we're I all
of a sudden if you have one belief that
now you are on the left side of the
fence or whatever that's silly I do want
to talk about can you be racist against
whites that's a weird question is come
up a lot on Twitter recently
identity politics this this new term
Karen's that's out there right now which
is is something I want to talk about but
what what did I love that like every
time like okay boomer comes out Karen
comes out they always liken it to the
most derogatory word you could say right
the n-word Oh like Karen is just like
the end it's like no it's no who is it
Mark Manson was like no it's not you're
saying Karen I wanna talk about my wife
back to her encounter with some
anti-white racism on social media which
was was fascinating and
rather troubling for her and we'll talk
about that I want to talk about the best
way for Richard Spencer to recruit
racists I want talk about
microaggressions and a whole lot more
we're gonna do that on this week's
maximal episode on the minimalist
private podcast it's just a couple bucks
it's totally separate endeavor by the
way this is a place where we actually
talk even more candidly about things
that we don't don't necessarily talk
about in public cuz it's just five or
six thousand people in a private group
of hours it's called the minimalist
private podcast you can check it out the
minimalists dot-com slash support you
can become a supporter over there that
keeps this podcast 100 percent
advertisement free so thank you for that
so head on over there if you want more
of this but before but we wrap up here
TK I thought we would talk about
something actionable what do we do at
this point this isn't me like being the
white guy say hey what are those whites
do tell me black guy but what I'm saying
is what do we do as humans at this point
we're seeing tension we're seeing racism
clear racism we're seeing injustice
we're also seeing some justice
apparently it appears that today the the
cop who murdered Floyd was was arrested
and so that appears to be at least a
part of the the justice system or
justice happening here but what do we
what do we do as humans besides I mean
obviously I think it's good to have
conversations like this with people who
are who are willing to have these
conversations you don't have to have
them in public like we are and I know
that comes at a great cost for many of
you I can't be canceled which is really
nice you're right and we don't we don't
have anywhere I'll be challenging our
audience
yeah cancel me you can't actually you
that's the funny thing you as a as a
listener can cancel this you can
unsubscribe you can cancel your your
patreon subscription or whatever and
that's the only way you can cancel us
but we have supportive people we're not
beholding to you know tied or whoever we
don't have sponsors or yeah yeah
contracts with yeah I see exactly and so
we're gonna be fine in that respect so
we can have these kind of conversations
publicly but it comes at a great cost
for some people to have these
conversations publicly
yeah BJ Thompson was on my revolution of
one podcast and we talked about that
like by the way feed org slash rev one
yeah check it out check it out great
video version man it's we need to show
Jordan the video over there looks really
good I appreciate it brother
but yet we're talking about how can you
find the courage to be bold because we
all have things that we want to say but
then there are prices to pay and one of
the things he talked about is equity
then this is one of the great arguments
for equity for for the application of
entrepreneurial thinking to every area
of your life the less you are beholden
to people the more free you are to be
who you truly are the more of yourself
that you have to censor because well you
know I don't want to offend TGI Fridays
you know with what I really think about
this issue then then the less freedom
you have and you don't have to despise
yourself a being in that situation you
just have to you have to make trade-offs
but but this is actually a good argument
for things like creating wealth or for
making the investments necessary to give
yourself the kind of freedom in your
career to do things the way you want to
do them and that doesn't just take the
form of becoming independently wealthy
it can also mean hey I'm not gonna take
money from people that I don't want to
be beholden to even if that solves
problems overnight you know it's funny
you mentioned that we I just had a phone
call with WME who represents us there
are our agencies are booking agency but
uh someone from their podcast space and
they were talking to me about how we
could go to a particular streaming
platform and as long as we're willing to
read ads for them issues like well you
know how much do you make from your
little patreon thing she say oh you make
like 30 times that if you went to this
platform like that sounds awesome but I
can't read ads for other people right
like I'm not allergic to money but I am
allergic to being beholden to it to to
advertisers or gatekeepers or people who
are telling me what I'm supposed to say
and when I'm supposed to say it
yeah Josh I need you to you know tone it
down on those jokes right yeah
you need to say african-american what do
we do what do you mean what do we do as
human beings we are in and as Americans
but you know only about 50% of the
podcasts are our Americans of the
listenership are our Americans so what
do we do as as humans because I mean
it's clearly every Baptist to fight this
yeah I mean every country besides this
is more racist than America anyway so if
you live outside of America you're even
in a worse situation than where we are I
get these other countries man if they
act now it's it's fascinating to me
because we want to shout a lot on social
media right and in you notice there was
no shouting here today there's a lot of
listening and trying to understand I
want to listen a lot more and understand
we do this maximal episode together as
well and we're gonna dive deeper into
some things that are even more
contentious I feel like but if we're
leaving listeners with something to do I
mean to me if I'm prescribing something
it's trying to understand people better
why and I have a formula for
understanding people it's an acronym
Tara tolerate accept respect and then
eventually appreciate that's a those are
big steps the first step is tolerance I
think it's a really weak virtue you
don't just want to tolerate people
because you doesn't feel very good but
that is the first step toward
understanding someone is tolerating that
someone has a different belief a
different set of values a different set
of standards or expectations from you
and so we have to start with that weak
first step but from there we're able to
accept like okay I'm accepting that
we're difference maybe we have different
opinions maybe we voted for different
people I can accept that right and then
eventually I can respect the fact that
Ryan in the 2016 election voted for
someone different from me and not just
accepting it but I respect that he is an
individual human being and we don't have
to agree on everything and I respect him
as a human and therefore I respect the
decisions he makes even though I would
may not make the same decision and
ultimately the final giant leap is to
appreciate and I in you can it's
Jonathan Franzen who said you
in love a whole human without liking
every piece of them yeah and I think
that's ultimately how we understand
someone we get through that whole
process of tolerance all the way to
appreciation for someone and so so
there's something about understanding
people here that I think we can do TK
what do you think we can do yeah you
know if I were to gather a group of
people in the into a room and and our
goal was to come up with the solution to
a problem my first question to myself
would not be what's the solution my
first question would be do I have the
right people in the room right if we're
gonna have conversations about solution
solutions I think the first step is to
expand the boundaries of that
conversation to expand the space within
which that conversation happens too many
conversations about what we should do
happen amongst the same people right
it's the same group of people having the
same conversation so that makes it
difficult for us to challenge our own
thinking that makes it difficult for us
to step outside of our own habitual
thought patterns and discover something
new it leads to what I call creative
solipsistic salep system is the position
that i am the only one that exists and
everything else exists inside my own
consciousness creative solipsistic reate
solutions it all comes from you and from
social circles that reflect you and so I
what the challenge that I would make
because I don't think talk is cheap
I think talk is very costly if you're
having the right kind of conversation
with the right kind of people and I
believe that talk can challenge you to
the core my challenge to people would be
go seek out conversations with people
that you haven't had conversations with
before you know and and go take on that
challenge but I might offend them well
those are the kinds of conversations you
need to be in because if you don't know
what you need to do and avoid in order
to not be offensive and that kind of
frightens you then that means there are
some spaces that you haven't
familiarized yourself with that means
there are some spaces that you haven't
explored that means you've been in your
comfort zone you should never have all
of your conversations in a space where
you know exactly what to expect from
that other person right you know exactly
how to play
safe because that's what makes it easy
for us to hide and and and so I'm all
about saying hey instead of me putting
down three four ideas or giving you
official you can eat for the day let me
teach you how to fish so you can eat for
a lifetime and the way that you do that
is create greater space around the
conversations that you have talk with
people they ain't like you mm-hmm yeah
yeah the only thing I would add to that
is you talk less and listen more to
those people Thanks yeah yeah yeah I
think that you know that's one thing I
learned especially when we were doing
the the quarantine conversations over
the which you did one of those with me
TK over on patreon we did 40 of these
quarantine conversations and at the
beginning I found myself talking a lot
and as I listen back I'm like oh why
didn't I just give them more room in and
part of that giving them more room is
being comfortable with some silence or
being comfortable with a little bit of
discomfort or awkwardness and if we can
do that if we can make the room that
then yeah it's that's minimalism right
when you when you declutter your home
there's a particular calm there but the
process is a bit awkward in between and
we're gonna have some awkward
conversations but in a weird way sort of
decluttering the the preconceived
notions you're decluttering the comfort
in a way as well you're letting go of
that need for perpetual comfort we don't
want to be wrapped in bubble wrap or you
don't want our conversations to be
wrapped in bubble wrap either sometimes
they're gonna be raw they're gonna be
honest and something that's raw I had
this conversation with our editor of our
next book I love people use things where
there's a whole chattering about truth
and I'm like the truth isn't neat and
tidy right and it it's strangely complex
now our job is to simplify that but when
you simplify it is going to be messy and
so some of these conversations you're
talking about CK they're gonna be messy
and you might you might pay an emotional
price for that but I think you'll grow
in the process and hey man I'm living by
example right here I'm being truly
honest when I say that if you give me
any topic to talk about based on what I
enjoy and what I
for I'm taking personal development
every single time I want to talk about
human potential I want to talk about
expanding your sense of possibility I
want to talk about achieving your dreams
I want to talk about solving conflict in
your personal relationships I want to
talk about building your self-esteem
that's the kind of stuff that fires me
up you know but when there's a
discussion on something like this it's
it's riskier right like this is a space
where like I'm far more likely to make
somebody upset than if I'm just talking
about you know how we all have the right
to pursue our dreams right and I'm far
more likely to get something wrong then
if I just stay in a safer environment of
like a man like work hard do the best
that you can man don't know don't let
nobody tell you to take off you know
it's just so much more difficult man
yeah but but I don't run from it I don't
I don't I don't avoid it
I don't beg people not to do it I think
we need role models that are willing to
step up and say you know what I don't
know everything about this I'm open to
learning but I'm not afraid of this you
know I made up my mind a long time ago
that I'm never gonna let people see me
squirm with any question they ask me I'm
never gonna beg for relief when it comes
to a certain question or topic I'm just
gonna if you give me something that I
don't want then I'm gonna run into it
even faster right because that's where
growth is like run tour it's those
conversations then you're afraid to
happen if you can't we've got a lot more
to talk about on the maximal episode if
you all want to check that out the
minimalists comm slash support that'll
be out on Thursday follow TK Coleman on
Twitter at TK underscore Coleman I think
you're at official TK Coleman on
instagram is that's right that's right
I'm official now as well TK Coleman Comi
has a great blog over there make sure
you subscribe to that wonderful thoughts
from TK Coleman and then you've got your
show revolution of 1000 you don't have
to write down if you're driving or
something it'll all be in the show notes
by the way if you want our show notes in
your inbox just sign up for our email
list over at the minimalists com I will
also send you our simple Sunday emails
each week if you have a comment question
or minimalism tip for our podcast you
can send a voice memo to podcast at the
lists calm you can also follow the
minimalists on Instagram Twitter and
Facebook at the minimalist you can see
one of our live podcast shows which TK
is gonna be at one of them I think the
Sacramento shows that's right
yeah so we got a bunch of shows coming
up once this whole quarantine business
is over you can find those at the
minimalists comm a slash tour I think
it's all we got right now I will see you
on the maximum weapon so later this week
we got a lot more to talk about
all right y'all love people use things
the opposite never works see you next
time bye
every little scene you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you'll be fine
without
[Music]